>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> A man I have the honor
of introducing today
needs little introduction
to a literary crowd such as this.
With 23 books to his name Richard
Rhodes is among the most prolific
authors here today.
His best known work maybe
the making of the atomic bomb
for which he won a Pulitzer Prize in
non fiction, a National Book Award,
a National Book Critics Circle
Award, and it was the first volume
in a series about the
makings of the nuclear age,
a project that has absorbed
him for more than 20 years.
His new book for which
he is on a book tour
at the moment is the
fourth and final volume
in that epic series The
Twilight of the Bombs.
It examines the civilization's
changes brought
about by nuclear technology
in the post cold war years,
the securing of the former Soviet
nuclear arsenal, the first Iraq war
and the lead up to the second, the
prospects for nuclear abolition
and an issue that I think
preoccupies us all here today the
risk of nuclear terrorism but when
I mentioned to one of my colleagues
that I'd be introducing
Richard Rhodes he said, "Aha!
The nuclear bomb guy."
Many of you probably think of him
that way but take a quick spin
through a list of his published
works and you'll see what a diverse
and accomplished author he is.
He has written about dogs
and of course of horses,
two of my favorite subjects, about
greeting cards and cannibalism,
about sex and soy beans, and
he's done it in the Rolling Stone
and the Journal of Chemical
Education, in Playboy and of course
in the pages of the Washington Post.
Among his 23 published books
are 4 works of fiction,
a personal memoir and a biography.
He's been host and correspondent
for public TV's Frontline
and he's written at least
one play Reykjavik based
on the historic 1986
summit in Iceland
between Gorbachev and Ronald Reagan.
Most of what he's written is
what I would call nonfiction
and what he I think has another
term for and I'm going to ask him
to elucidate that for
us a little bit.
Let me invite him to explain it
and tell us more about the Twilight
of the Bombs and also for
anybody who would like hear more
from him he will be speaking
and signing books at Politics
and Prose tonight at 6 o'clock
so please invite your
friends along to that too.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you very much.
It seems really appropriate to
follow Henry because he was talking
about Leo Szilard and of course the
making of the atomic bomb begins
with the day Leo in 1933 walked
across the street in London
and thought of the idea of a
nuclear chain reaction that kind
of started this whole
story moving forward.
This last volume that
I've just published--
let's see, here is
at least the front,
there's a wonderful bomb
test winding around the back
and I think it will be the last,
picks up the story at the end
of the Cold War just before the
collapse of the Soviet Union
and it's metastases into
four nuclear powers instead
of one nuclear power which was a
great challenge to our government
and our diplomats and
carries it forward
to approximately the present.
Perhaps the turning point
or the ending point being President
Obama's historic speech at Prague
in the spring of 2009
when he announced it
as official US Government policy
to move toward the complete
elimination of all nuclear weapons.
A dream that had-- yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> A dream that had
also been a theme
of President Ronald Reagan's life
who he had indeed since the end
of the second world war have
been puzzling over the question
of how you could get rid of
nuclear weapons but he turned
to a technological
solution to the problem.
So in my play where Robert
Oppenheimer comes back to life
from the dead to-- because
they needed a character
who could stand outside
the story and comment on it
and of course Robert Oppenheimer
being Robert Oppenheimer
as it is he steps on stage he takes
over the play but be that as it may,
at some point Oppenheimer says
to Reagan well, but you know,
you are trying to solve a
problem that's a political problem
with a technological solution and
then Reagan says to him well isn't
that what your bombs were anyway?
And he was right, he is right.
We got into this business
during the war because we feared
that the Germans had a
considerable lead, we continued it
because we were frightened of
the Soviet Union's capabilities
and we continue it after
the end of the cold war
with considerable difficulty in
rationalizing why we still need
so many nuclear weapons
in our arsenal.
So I picked up the story
at that point and deal
with the serious problems we had
in trying to put the nuclear genie
that had-- was now spread across
4 countries not only Russia
but also Belarus and Kazakhstan
and Ukraine, how we convince
over the next 5 years those
countries other than Russia
to send their arsenals
back to Russia
to sign a nuclear nonproliferation
treaty and become non-nuclear states
and that's quite a story in itself.
But there was so much more going
on, the image that I opened the book
with is the sentence, when the
ice broke on the river of history
at the end of the Cold War
and because the world had been
so polarized for the previous
40 or 50 years it's true
that in a sense everything
came loose
and each individual nation
state had to think about finding
or adjusting it's relationship
to the rest of the world.
And I think that accounts
for the diminished fifth
of new third world nuclear
powers, a very few of them
but certainly North Korea and Iraq--
I'm sorry, and Pakistan that emerged
after the end of the Cold War as
those countries tried to figure
out where they were and what
their relationship would be
with the new world that
was no longer bipolar
but was now multi polar,
multi lateral.
One of the things that I write about
and that I think you will enjoy
in this new book was the inspections
in Iraq after the first Gulf War.
You remember that President Bush
the first elicited an argument
about an Iraqi Nuclear Weapons
Program as one reason for that war.
It turns out that the reason he
did so was that he was concerned
that after we cleared the Iraqis out
of Kuwait it might not be possible
in terms of international politics
to justify continuing into Iraq
and reducing the scale of Iraq's
military forces which was the plan.
Therefore, he had to invent, which
he did, an Iraqi Nuclear Program,
we did not know there was
such a thing at the time.
There were hints but
no real evidence
so imagine everyone's surprise after
that very brief war when it turned
out there were in deed Iraqi nuclear
facilities under development all
over the country, a
very large scale program
that in some ways corresponded
to the Manhattan Project here
in this country and that they
were trying different methods
for enriching uranium and so forth.
The stories that I heard from
David Kay and Bob Gallucci
who were the two Americans who
led those inspections for the IAEA
and for the United
Nations were wonderful cops
and robber stories among
other things because our guys
with some kind of broken down UN
land rovers were chasing the Iraqis
around their own country.
In particular we had hints that
they were using an old World War II
technology to enrich uranium
which is called Cyclotron
or electromagnetic
isotope separation
that involved magnet cores
that weighed 60 tons and were
about 15 feet in diameter.
They were big discuss-shaped soft
iron cores for the big magnets
that would separate
the different isotopes
of uranium and enrich it thereby.
The Iraqis were loading these huge
magnet cores onto tank transporters
which are huge flatbed trucks
and as we came in the front door
in our land rovers we, the
inspectors, they were driving
out the back door of the base with
these magnet cores on big trucks.
So Bob and David talked
about chasing around,
being fired into the air by the
Iraqis, because they were trying
to get television footage
of this equipment
to prove that they had seen it.
>> And of course eventually
tracking down the materials
and either removing
them from their country
or destroying them
by blowing them up.
You remember the days
when the team was stuck
in a parking lot outside the
Department of Agriculture
in downtown Baghdad
because as they--
Kay told me they had found down in
a basement room of the Department
of Agriculture the actual
plans for an Iraqi bomb.
And they were determined to get
those documents out of that building
and in fact by the time the parking
lots standoff occurred the documents
were already gone.
I asked David Kay how they
snuck them out and he said,
well we had these great Kiwi
medics who were helping us out.
He said, I had a guy on my
team who had the worst case
of diarrhea I'd ever seen
and he had to be taken out
and the Iraqis agreed to let him
go, he said so we gave the documents
to the Kiwis they stuffed
them in their shirt
and carried the stretcher out the
door and the documents were safe
but they didn't want to
tell the Iraqis that,
the Iraqis weren't prepared
to let them go until they gave
up the documents and so
for 4 days they stood
in that parking lot
unsure of their fate.
This has its comic side but
it was very serious business.
Their lifeline to the outside world
was a 1991 type satellite telephone
and they were on that phone the
first of the four days nonstop
for 23 hours to CNN and any other
news media that as the satellite
or as the earth turned they were
able to hit different time zones
and they continued their
radio broadcasting.
But at 23rd hour approximately
there was a break and they hung
up the phone Kay said and it
immediately rang and Kay picked it
up and it was the operator in
London who said you've been
on the phone now for 23 hours
we don't know what you're doing
but we need a credit
card [laughter].
And Kay said I told them, well,
you're not getting my
damn credit card but--
he said but let me tell
you what's happening here.
So he explained to the operator
among other things that their--
the reception on the
satellite was kind of weak
and the signal varied a lot and the
operator said well let me get back
to you, I'll call you back,
and about 30 minutes later the
phone rang and the operator came on
and he said now that we understand
what this is about we're going
to move the satellite for you.
[Laughter] And they
could maintain that link
until the Iraqis finally gave up
and they were allowed to leave.
[ Pause ]
>> The book also deals with the
crisis with North Korea in 1994.
I think it's not generally
known how very close
to a second Korean War
we came at that time.
You'll recall that the North
Koreans had built a reactor
at Yongbyon north of Seoul
and had been negotiating back
and forth again with Bob Gallucci.
Bob Gallucci seems to have been
the indispensable man in the '90s.
He's now the president of
the McArthur Foundation so,
in some ways he's still
indispensable
but some glitches had come up and
the Iraqis basically pulled out
and were talking about going
ahead and taking the plutonium
from their one reactor,
taking the uranium, the fuel,
and extracting the plutonium
and making their first bombs.
This became very close
to a war scale crisis
within the Clinton administration
because we were threatening
to impose increasing sanctions on
the North Koreans as you may recall,
we were threatening to turn
Seoul into a sea of fire.
In fact, Gallucci told me that we
were within a day or two of war
and that we were just about to
evacuate the American Embassy
and all the other embassies in Seoul
which as he understood it would have
been a signal to the North Koreans
that war was about to come and
that they probably would have moved
preemptively to attack
Seoul had that happened.
General Locke who was in
charge of our forces in Korea
around this time told President
Clinton that we could win the war
with North Korea but that the cost
would be a million and a trillion
and the president said
what does that mean?
And General Locke said a
million South Korean lives
and a trillion dollars extracted
from the South Korean economy
because of the destruction
of that war.
So those were the stakes.
And you'll recall that
Jimmy Carter much
to President Clinton's disgust
stepped forward and went
as a private citizen to North Korea
and settled things
down with Kim Il-sung.
Then Bob Gallucci went
back to his business
of negotiating with
the North Koreans.
Kim Il-sung died almost immediately
and his son came to power.
Negotiations went forward
very successfully
but didn't quite finish
the job by the end
of the Clinton administration.
Madeleine Albright went to North
Korea, I believe, in December even
after the election and President
Clinton was prepared to go himself
but because that election
of the year 2000 was mooted
he didn't feel he should leave
the country.
And then when the Bush
administration came
in they had a very different
attitude toward North Korea
and things kind of
fell apart after that.
But that million and a trillion just
reminds you, reminds me certainly
of how many times since the
beginning of the Cold War and even
since the end of the cold
war we have come very close
to at least a large
scale conventional war,
if not indeed some kind of
nuclear exchange in the world.
So I looked later in
the book at the question
of how can we resolve this
dilemma if we feel nuclear weapons
in some sense are important
to our security
but if we feel we'd be more
secure if there were none
in the world and indeed we would.
In fact one of the problems with
getting rid of nuclear weapons is
that the United States would be
relatively speaking even more
powerful with conventional forces
only given our enormous capacity
compared to other countries than
it is now when even small states
such as North Korea can
effectively stand us off
with a small nuclear capability.
If there's any reason why Iran
might be moving toward a nuclear
capability that and Israel's
capability are certainly two
of the reasons.
There is a commission in 1996 called
by the Australian Prime Minister
called the Canberra Commission.
Richard Butler the Ambassador
from Australia for Nuclear Issues
and Nuclear Disarmament told me
that the most important thing he
felt came out of that commission
of international leaders
on this subject was what he
calls the axiom of proliferation.
For him this is the bottom
line of the whole question
of who has nuclear weapons.
Who should have them or how
we should get rid of them.
And it goes like this.
So long as any state has nuclear
weapons other states will seek
to acquire them.
That means that ultimately
if you want a world safe
from nuclear weapons
everyone has to give them up.
That's an immensely
complicated problem obviously,
sometimes I think saying we have to
all disarm our nuclear weapons is
like saying we have to settle
world peace then we won't need
them anymore.
It's almost that complicated.
But it is there as
a fundamental fact
which President Obama paraphrased
in his Prague speech by saying
which is really kind of the next
step in this series of axioms,
if we believe that the spread of
nuclear weapons is inevitable then
in some way we are admitting
to ourselves that the use
of nuclear weapons is inevitable.
We've dodged that bullet
now since 1949,
since the Soviet Union
became the second state
to acquire a nuclear arsenal.
But how much longer
will we be so lucky?
How many times since those
first days have we been
within a hairs breadth
of a nuclear exchange?
I have cited in my works
the Cuban Missile Crisis
and the Able Archer
event in Europe in 1983
when the Soviets thought we
might be preparing to attack them
and seriously considered
striking us first.
But I've talked to people who
should be in a position to know
in our government who have said
oh yeah those too, but you know,
there were a lot more that
haven't' come to light yet.
So we really have been quite lucky.
Getting rid of nuclear weapons is
going to mean ultimately dealing
with conflicts situations
that are thorny indeed.
>> Most of all Israel, North Korea,
Iran, and in my mind the country
that is going to be the hardest
nut to crack, the hardest
and most difficult place to convince
to give up it's nuclear arsenals,
our country, the United States.
We started all these, we maintained
all these for whatever reasons,
good or bad or indifferent, a lot
of I think the Cold War had to do
with domestic politics not with
relations with the Soviet Union,
you can read about that
in this book as well.
But the fact is we're the ones
who I think will have
the greatest difficulty.
And one of the reasons is
a simple practical fact.
We spend about 50 billion dollars a
year maintaining a nuclear arsenal
that is basically utterly
useless except
as a display of potential force.
That's a lot of money, it supports
a lot of people and industries
and I think it's going
to be difficult indeed
to wind all that down.
Yes? Thank you.
So let me just quickly end.
There's much more in
the book including
and I won't give you the
details you'll have to read it,
including the real reason we went
to war with Iraq the second time.
Which I will just say had to do with
anthrax not with nuclear weapons.
At the end, I come back to the
question how do we do this?
And I look at a model that
I've written about before
that I'm sure you've read in my
books before but it seems to me
as a fundamental model for
how you live in a world
without nuclear weapons
and that is the model
of the public health system.
We lived once with a
kind of universal scourge
which was epidemic disease and the--
a few reformers and then
later medical doctors
and researchers found
fairly straightforward ways
to identify the source of a disease,
to isolate the carriers of a disease
and in a few cases in this--
in the 20th century even to begin
the process of eliminating disease,
small pox, most of all which most
of us don't even think anymore.
Polio, the elimination
is almost complete today.
There has been no polio in the
western hemisphere since 1991.
And the states that still have polio
cases are not surprisingly the ones
that have the least infrastructure
and the least support.
So I discussed at some
length that analogy
and I think you might find it
interesting to look at and think
about because we have a success
story where millions upon millions
of lives were saved
and are still safe
because of some fairly straight
forward ways of thinking about--
of relating to the
natural world differently
from the way we related before.
I think the same thing is
possible with manmade death
as with biologic death but manmade
debt is actually a harder problem
because people and their motives
and their needs, their expectation
and their fears are all involved.
So let me stop there and take any
questions or comments you have.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Yes?
>> At the dawn of the atomic age
some people thought the genie could
be stopped and others thought it was
inevitable, just a matter of time.
Do you think it could
have been stopped
and what do you think people
will think another 100 years out?
How do you think this will
evolve that thinking over time?
>> Could they have kept the
genie pushed down in the bottle
or was the development of
nuclear weapons inevitable?
You know, I always quote something
Robert Oppenheimer once said
that I think speaks
exactly to this question.
He said the deep things
in science are not found
because they are useful.
They were found because it
was possible to find them.
Nuclear fission was an
inevitable outcome of the studies
of the nucleus of the atom
of the atom that began
in the early years
of the 20th century.
You reach a certain point and you
inevitably find nuclear fission.
Once nuclear fission was found--
and I say inevitable because
scientists all over the world
when they got the word that
2 German radio chemists
that identified this amazing
new reaction scientists all
over the world kicked themselves.
They understood that they've
been seeing it in their labs
but because they hadn't
thought through what was going
on they hadn't identified
what it was.
And I mean really, I've talked to
a number of them who were just sick
for a couple of days after
this huge discovery was made
that they missed just because
they didn't think it through.
So, it inevitably came along and
the idea that this was some sort
of falsity and bargain on
the part of the scientist
that they all could have
gone off in a room somewhere
up in a mountain top and said, oh
let's not do this, is simply absurd.
There it was and the reaction was so
fiercely exothermic, so much energy
out for so little energy in.
And in the context of the discovery
having been made nine months before
the beginning of the
Second World War
in Europe inevitably people would
think of the possibility of a bomb.
Now what followed from that
and the nuclear arms raise those
inevitably were political decisions
made for many different
kinds of reasons.
I think fundamentally, at least
at the beginning, from deep fears
that the only defense
against these weapons
which the scientists
recognized as early
as 1939 would be similar arsenal
and the threat of retaliation.
That kept it going for a long time.
So I think that's a full
answer to that question.
Yes?
>> Yes. A lot of people don't
know there was this genius--
genius, genius in Meredith Gardner
and he broke the indecipherable
ciphers that the Soviet's used
and this is called
the VENONA messages.
>> Oh yes, right.
>> Into 30s and to 40s and
he broke them in the 50s
and if you read the VENONA
messages I think you will find some
justification as to why we
have atomic bombs [laughter]
but the second thing is in the
VENONA messages I always knew,
every one that knew that
[inaudible], green glass,
definitely as the Rosenberg
and Julia state they didn't have
access to the atomic secrets.
A man that did that was messaged--
a young American called Ted Hall,
Theodore Hall and yet he immigrated
to the United States-- England.
>> In England, yeah.
>> He was a Cambridge
professor and he died old age.
He was never put to
death or anything.
>> Right.
>> And he gave the Soviets
most of the usable secrets.
>> That's correct.
>> Can you comment on
both of those two things?
>> Yeah, I think, you know,
it's always puzzled me why Ted Hall
was allowed to live out his life.
I think that suggest that he had new
things or had documents or something
that our government security
people didn't want to see released,
that's usually why
people aren't touched.
But the larger question, I'll
just speak to it with an anecdote,
could the Soviets have build an
atomic bomb within the timeframe
that they did about the same time
it took us without the secrets
that were passed to
them by their spies?
And I corresponded with this Soviet
Robert Oppenheimer a man named
[inaudible] in the
last years of his life
by the new thing e-mail
back in the early '90s.
And he pointed out that by 1947
they had worked out a bomb design
that would be half as heavy,
half as big and twice as powerful
as our first bomb as
our Nagasaki bomb.
And I said why didn't you do--
build that one instead of
building a copy of ours?
And he said because Lavrentiy
Beria who was the monster
who ran the Gulag system
and was also in charge
of their bomb program had said
to them with great contempt,
I don't give a damn what you
think is a workable design.
Build me the American
bomb I know it works.
He said it was worth our lives
so we built the American bomb
that's what my government wanted.
But then I noticed in
looking at the list
of their tests their second
bomb test was of a bomb that was
about half the size and twice
the yield of our Nagasaki bomb.
So they built theirs next
after they've fulfilled
the political requirements
that were there for
them to deal with.
Sir?
>> Do you believe that Iran has any
interest in a nuclear power program
or is it just solely a
nuclear weapons program?
>> You know I think
there's-- I think it's--
there's ample of reason to believe
that Iran is following basically
the path that Israel followed.
The sort of bomb in the basement not
acknowledged that we are building
such a thing or have
built such a thing.
It was a very successful
path for Israel,
still is in many ways to this day.
It leaves an ambiguity there
about their relationship
to being a nuclear power,
even though everyone knows
they are a nuclear power.
So that seems to me
what Iran is doing
but it's been progressing
very slowly
which isn't just the
technological problems,
although there are plenty of those.
Arguably what they are doing is
as North Korea has been doing
in a much more blatant way
trying to use their capabilities
as a negotiating tool
to find some settlement
with the United Stats in particular.
North Korea, without question,
and you will read this
in the books several chapters
may surprise you amazingly
about North Korea's reasons
for developing nuclear weapons.
>> Primarily it was because during
the Korean War we systematically,
strategically bombed North
Korea back to the Stone Age just
as Curtis LeMay had
threatened to do.
We particularly destroyed all of
their hydroelectric dams as well
as a lot of dams that controlled the
flood control for their rice fields.
I mean it's a horrible story.
We killed several million
North Korean civilians
with strategic bombing
just as we had done
against Japan during
the Second World War
with perhaps more justification
in that case.
Under those circumstances
the main goal of Kim Il-sung
for many years thereafter was to get
an alliance with the United States
that would allow North Korea
to rebuild an electrical capacity
probably based on nuclear power.
And it has been for that
purpose down through the years
with other things thrown in
needless to say the presence
of American nuclear weapons in South
Korea, the long standing conflict
between North and South Korea
basically a long standing Civil War.
All that's been there,
but underneath it all,
and you'll hear it
every time you hear
about what the North Koreans are
bringing to the negotiating table,
they want an electrical supply.
I mean, that's kind
of where we still are.
When Bob Gallucci negotiated
the deal with them
for two nuclear power
reactors of western design
that the South Koreans would supply,
I said why did you give them that?
He said that's what they wanted.
And of course, they would be
under international control
and all those things but-- so
it's not always what one reads
in the papers that these are
crazy people and so forth.
There really is a practical
reason why North Korea would
like get a head start
on becoming a country
like its cousins of the South.
They were actually economically
better off than South Korea
until the late 1970's
and it was then
that they decided they needed a
program of nuclear development
which may or may not include a bomb.
Eventually it did include a bomb.
Do we have any time left?
>> Time, it's over time.
>> Thanks so much.
[ Applause ]